hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem surrounded
regions this is a pretty interesting
problem and I think you're going to be
really surprised by the solution that we
come up with today and I definitely
think this problem is well worth your
time so now let's get into it in this
problem we're given an M byn Matrix
board containing only X's and O's and we
want to capture all regions that are
four directionally surrounded by x's and
by the way capturing a reason I don't
know if you can hear that flight noise
there's an airplane above but let's
continue the problem capturing a region
is defined by flipping all of the O's
into X's if and only if those O's happen
to be surrounded by x's and this is best
understood with an example so let's take
a look at this input board this is the
input board and this is the result so
how do we get to the result well take a
look at the board here we have two
different regions of O's this is one
region let me use a different color this
is one region and this is the second
region why are these separate regions
aren't they connected diagonally well
yeah they're connected diagonally but
remember look above we only want four
directionally surrounded right so
basically these cannot be connected
diagonally they have to be connected
horizontally or vertically like these
three are so these are two separate
regions in the result you can see that
this region was flipped right one of the
regions was flipped right why was this
region flipped because take a look it's
surrounded by X's right there's an X
here x here x here x here x here x here
uh by the way actually we don't care
about this x because this x is diagonal
right we care about horizontal and
vertical X's so this x this x this X
this X and I think this is the last X
right it's surrounded by all X's so
therefore we can capture this region
when we say capture we mean convert the
O's into X's as you can see in the
output what about the second region
isn't this region also surrounded by X's
why didn't we flip it in the output well
let's take a look this is has an x on
the left of it has an X above it has an
x to the right of it but at the bottom
there's no X it's on on the border right
so because this region is connected to
the Border we're not going to flip it
right so basically any regions that are
not connected to the Border are going to
be flipped only the regions that are not
connected to the border so how can we
solve this problem should we run a DFS
on you know the entire board and then
try to figure out somehow which regions
are not connected to the border and then
flip them well definitely that is
possible but depending on how you do it
that's a complicated approach actually
there are many ways to solve this
problem I'm going to show you a slightly
clever and easy way to solve this
problem but I think you can actually
learn a lot from the type of solution
I'm going to show you it has to do with
reversing the way you think about the
problem what I and some people like to
call reverse thinking so let's get into
that solution right now so up above you
can see the example that we're trying to
solve this General problem we're trying
to solve but before we even get into
that let me just kind of ask you a
simple question let's say I had a piece
of paper like this one let's say I cut
it like this right I have a small region
over here called a this is the a portion
of the paper and I have a other portion
this is the B portion of the paper let's
say I want to keep only this portion I
only want to keep the a portion of the
paper so how can I ask for the a portion
of the paper well I can say only give me
a right only the a portion of the paper
that's the simple way to talk about it
but a more complicated and kind of a
useless way to talk about it in English
at least would be would be to say give
me everything in the paper except for B
right give me this entire paper except
for B right just cross B out just give
me everything except for B why would you
say that when you can just say just give
me a right of course that's the simp way
to say it but sometimes this reverse way
of thinking can be helpful especially in
programming I'm sure you guys already
have kind of experienced that so how is
this going to be helpful in this problem
let me explain in the problem they told
us to capture they told us to capture
the surrounding regions only right only
the surrounding regions in other words
only this region that's surrounded
another way the opposite way of saying
that is capture everything except the
UNS surrounded regions right I basically
restated the first bullet point with a
longer sentence right capture everything
in this board except the UNS surrounded
regions the regions that are not
surrounded in other words capture the
entire board except for this region
because this region is not surrounded
how do we know that this region is not
surrounded is there an easy way to
figure that out yes it's very easy
because this region is connected to the
Border any any region in the board
connected to the border right there were
some O's over here some O's over here
here or down here we are not going to
capture those so this is where things
are going to get a little bit clever I
wouldn't expect most people to be able
to figure this part out especially
beginners how are we going to actually
implement this this second bullet point
basically we're going to go we're going
to scan through every border cell right
everything on the outside we're going to
look for any O's we found one o over
here right so we found one region that's
not surrounded right we know for sure
this region is UNS surrounded because
it's connected to the border now we're
going to run a DFS on on this region
because we don't want to capture it how
are we going to do that well we're going
to give it a temporary uh basically a
temporary value we're we're going to
change all the O's into T's so I'm going
to change this o into a t right now this
this o is not connected to anything
right it could be it could have been
possible maybe there's another o over
here and it kind of forms this region
that's connected to the border right and
then we would change all of those into
T's as well right but in this case it's
just a region of size one so that's all
we do now why are we changing it to a
temporary variable because remember
we're trying to capture everything
except unsur regions so now we we marked
this as a UNS surrounded region right so
now what are we going to do we have this
board we're going to just do a double
nested Loop iterate through every single
Row in this uh input grid and anytime we
see an O value we're going to change it
into an X because now we know for sure
that anytime we see an O It's defin
itely part of a surrounded region
because any regions that were UNS
surrounded we already changed them to a
t so anytime we see an O we're going to
change it to an X so what I'm going to
do is we see we see you know this is an
X leave it as it is X leave it we see an
O down here change it to an X Change
this to an X this is already an X Etc
change this to an X and this is already
an X when we get to this T we're going
to ignore T's right we're only changing
O's into X's right so that's the second
phase of the algorithm first we marked
T's now we're marking X's now the last
thing we have to do take a look at our
board and take a look at the desired
board that we want to return what's the
only difference basically the UNS
surrounded regions we change them to T's
but we still want them to be O's so
basically again we're going to do a
double scan we're a a a double four Loop
scan through the entire grid right
anytime we see a t we're going to change
it into back into an O so basically this
T over here would be changed you know
back into an O and then we have the
desired board that we want and we can
accomplish this we're going to have to
obviously iterate over the entire board
like two or three times or something so
that overall time complexity let's say
is going to be n * m where these are the
dimensions of the board but that is the
entire time complexity so I hope that
this solution makes sense to you so with
that being said I think we're ready to
dive into the code now okay so now let's
write out the code and you can see that
we don't have to actually return
anything we just have to modify the
board in place with these two
dimensional problems the first thing I
usually like to do is just get the
dimensions of the board so let's get the
number of rows and let's get the number
of columns I think we're guaranteed that
this board is always going to be
non-empty and I'm going to break this
algorithm up into three phases so the
first phase is going to be to capture
the unsur rounded regions remember all
the regions that are uh connected to the
Border we need to capture them and
change them into T's so any o is going
to be converted into a t for temporary
or something you could do any kind of
special character that you want the
second phase is going to be to capture
the surrounded regions right and we can
do that with a double for Loop right
we're basically going to be converting
O's into X's when we do this right all
the remaining O's are going to be
changed into x's and the last phase of
the algorithm is just going to be to uh
uncapture those UNS surrounded regions
so basically those t's are going to be
converted back into O's so these are the
three phases of the algorithm and by the
way only the first phase is going to
need DFS the second and third phases are
going to be four Loops only let's
actually write out that DFS because
we're going to be needing it so let's
write out a DFS for capture we're given
some coordinates let's call it row and
column we're only going to be converting
O's into X's or O's into T's now the
main thing is the base case so let's
write it out basically if we go out of
bound so if row is less than zero or
column is less than zero row is equal to
the number of rows which means it was
too big or column is equal to the number
of columns which means it also went out
of bounds and the other case is remember
we're only capturing O's so if the board
at this position is not an O then we can
also return so a board at row column is
not equal to an O then we can also
return so this has gotten to be a very
long line let me shorten it up a little
bit so that is the main base case and
the uh rest of the function is pretty
easy so if the base case did not execute
then we're going to be changing the uh
value at this uh position changing the O
into a t so let's change it into a t and
then we're basically just going to run
capture in the four adjacent Direction
so I'm just going to type that out you
could do it with a for Loop if you
wanted to but I'm lazy let's just copy
paste this a couple times so this will
be row minus one this will be column +
one and the next will be column minus
one so we're looking in all four
adjacent directions and capturing only
the O's right because that's our base
case if we go out of bounds or if we get
to something that's not an O we're not
going to capture it this function is
only going to be run on the border cell
so let's do phase one of the algorithm
let's do a double nested for Loop over
the entire grid even though this is not
actually necessary because technically
we're only going to be looking at the
border of the grid but I'm just coding
it up this way because it's short it
shortens up the code a little so we're
going to be iterating over the entire
board anytime we see a uh value that is
an O right we want O's so if we get to
an O and if this happens to be a border
cell right so B basically we're looking
for all the UNS surrounded regions which
are connected to the border and have O's
right because O's are regions so the way
I'm going to figure out if this is
connected to the border is basically if
row is in this pair of values either the
row is equal to zero or it's equal to
the number of rows minus one this is a
good way to do it in Python at least I
think so because we're basically doing
two comparisons in one we're checking if
row is equal to zero or equal to this
and we can also do it uh with another
thing so we're we're checking if this is
connected to the border so we're saying
if this is true and uh row Is On The
Border or uh the column is in the border
so we can say column is either equal to
zero or it's equal to columns minus one
so if this is a border cell what are we
going to do well we're going to capture
this region right so we can call our
helper function capture on this row and
column easy as that so we're already
done with phase one we've already
captured all UNS surrounded regions
converted them into T's and the next
portion of the algorithm is actually
going to be very trivial because we're
not going to even need DFS we're just
going to do a double nested for loop on
the entire grid and convert all O's into
X's right that's all we got to do this
is capturing the surrounded region so if
we ever see an O then we convert it into
a x right we don't even need to run DFS
on this because we don't even have to
figure out which regions are Sur rounded
all remaining O's are guaranteed to be
surrounded regions last but not least we
have to do phase three of the algorithm
which is just converting the t's back
into O's let me make some space so that
we can fit this all on one screen
basically that's going to be trivial as
well I'm just going to copy the above
for Loop that we did instead of checking
if it's equal to an O we're converting
T's into O's so if it's equal to T
convert it back into an O believe it or
not that is the entire algorithm I hope
this was broken down and easy to
understand let's run it to make sure
that it works and as you can see on the
left yes this solution does work and it
is pretty dang efficient so I really
hope that this was helpful if it was
please like And subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and hopefully I'll see
you pretty soon thanks for watching